y aquí estamos finalmente después de 11
años y 21 películas llegamos al final a
la conclusión de todo este fenómeno
mundial en el que se convirtió el
universo de marvel hace poco logra ver
avengers' en game así que acompaña mí a
ver si esta película cumple las
expectativas y es un final digno de la
saga el infinito
[Música]
acaba de decir antes de comenzar que
éste será un vídeo corto y sin spoilers
ya después de que pase un tiempo de que
la película sería estrenada y que todos
hayan tenido la oportunidad de verla
sacar un vídeo hablando de la película
con todos sus detalles pero por ahora no
he hacer nada que pueda cambiar en lo
más mínimo la experiencia de alguien al
ver la película pero en fin sobre la
pregunta que es el principio sobre si es
un buen cierre a esta saga del infinito
[ __ ] sí lo es esta película cumple con
las expectativas y la supera con creces
desde aquí atrás la sala de cine no me
sentía listo creo que ningún momento me
sentí listo para el final de todo esto y
la cantidad de formación que está a
punto de ver estaba nervioso y exaltado
pero es de que la película comienza
notas que el guión de la película fue
muy trabajado y la película en general
muy bien dirigida porque en ningún
momento llegas a notar que la película
se torna lenta o que te abruma con
muchas cosas sí es verdad que la
película es bastante larga pero su
duración no es porque solo quería hacer
una película larga y ya la película
tienen tantos temas que abarcar que fue
necesario y algo admirable es que en
ningún momento la película se siente
forzada en ninguno de los temas que
tratan usan muy bien el tiempo que
tienen a pesar de que hubiera sido
genial haber tenido un poco más de
tiempo para tratar los temas sobre todo
los últimos 8 minutos de la película un
poco mejor pero en sí todo estuvo muy
bien manejado
algo que sí me encantó es que al igual
que en infinity ward en game cuenta con
muchísimos personajes en los hermanos
russo logrando una manera asombrosa
darle su importancia a todos y cada uno
de los personajes claro no tanto como el
infinity ward pero aún así cada
personaje tiene momentos graciosos
momentos conmovedores momentos
memorables claro que ni en game es
notable que se centran principalmente
los vengadores originales no lo que es
iron man hulk por el carpio negra ok si
las prestan más atención a ellos pero
aún así se las arreglaron para darle su
tiempo importancia a todo si llegas a
ver incluso una falta muy distinta de
todos los personajes
además de eso esta película tiene el
estilo clásico de marvel no esa mezcla
entre escenas épicas de las tensas
combinadas con algo de comedia pero en
esta película siento que se llevó una
manera un poco mejor que en ocasiones
anteriores no existen forzados ni humor
tonto todo lo que verás está muy bien
posicionado el todas las escenas se
sienten muy cómodas sumado que la
película tiene un tono más serio y un
poco más adulto que otras cintas pero
que lo único que se puede criticar de la
película es que a ciertos personajes se
les da un trato distinto cuando haga la
reseña después de salvar esto más a
fondo aparte de eso es solo que abusan
del silla y en ocasiones pero consideró
que era algo necesario y créeme que
cuando estás viendo la película eso te
importa un [ __ ]
puedes preguntarle a quien quieras y
todos tuvieron lo mismo avengers' en
game es fun service puro y duro todo lo
que verás te va a gustar esta película
tan sentir que fue chat de fans para
fans créeme que no importa si viste
todos los trailers y spots de la
película no has visto nada
la película guarda muchas sorpresas y te
doy mi palabra que te va a encantar y
que será tus expectativas en que inter
al sentimiento que aun cuando salgas del
cine querrás verla de nuevo y de nuevo
para asimilar todo lo que la película te
presenta los hermanos russo hicieron un
trabajo excepcional presentarte
semejante película sí es cierto que ya
no hicieron que fall from homes en la
película que hiciera la fase 3 y no en
game para pesar de eso está claro que
después de verla en game es el final de
una era
obviamente el universo de marvel
continuará pero en game es el cierre de
unas etapas más fantásticas que ha
tenido el cine esta película para mí es
la mejor del 2019 hasta ahora y es una
de las mejores y más que la mejor de
todo marc webb no me queda más que darle
gracias a todos los que sean posible
todos estos años de entretenimiento años
en los que millones de fans nos unimos
por todo esto espero que así como yo
todo disfruten en game y el cierre de
esta asombrosa etapa
[Música]